Okay, folks.
I
I did hear from
So, on the final exam, I did hear from
some of you about the multiple choice
and
your being concerned about partial
credit. I'll work on making it more of a
regular exam rather than a multiple
choice. So, I I'll have to work through
exactly how to do it because
sending in attachments won't work
because 225 attachments come through,
it's going to be crazy. So, I'll have to
figure out a way in which you can have
the regular exam online and not do it
multiple choice. But, let me work on
that. But, for the moment, if you have
to make plans to fly out on, you know,
May 8th, May 9th instead of May 12th, go
ahead and do it because there will be an
online exam one way or the other.
Whether it's on whether it's, you know,
regular or multiple choice we'll work
through.
But, um you know, so, make your plans
based on that assumption.
Your second quiz is on Monday. So, make
sure that Yeah, go ahead.
That's a good question. If it's going to
be online, it has to be that same time
window because
how do you control
the process, right? You take the exam,
you know, I know there's an honor code,
but you know, you take it at different
times in the same day.
It's a it's very difficult to control
the fact that the exam will already be
out there.
So, if you cannot take it at that time,
let me know. I will figure out a way to
give you a different exam in the earlier
week. So, logistically, if you cannot
take it between 11:15 and 1:15 on
Monday, April 12th, which is the act I'm
sorry, May 12th, which is the actual
schedule time,
I need to know so I can figure out a
different exam to give you on a
different day. It can be online as well,
but it'll be a a different exam and be
the earlier week. And
so, we'll we'll figure out the logistics
of it one way or the other. We know
we'll we'll get that nailed down. So,
second quiz is next Monday. The third
quiz is 2 weeks after that. The second
quiz will cover everything in packet one
after
what we did for the first quiz where we
ended with betas and cost of equity. So,
we'll pick up with cost of debt, go
through the rest. Primarily investment
returns. What you did on the case is
pretty much what the second quiz is all
is going to be all about. Of course, in
less detail. You I can't ask you a big
question like that, but pieces of it
might show up.
Are there any any other logistical
administrative questions? Your final
project is due on the last day of class,
which is May 5th, which is a Monday. So,
if you haven't even met as a group, it
might be time to at least get that
process going so that you know that
people in the group are pulling their
weight getting the companies done or at
least starting to work on it.
So, today we're going to talk about the
financing mix, but today we're going to
talk about it
in less abstract form than we did last
session.
Last session we talked about the
trade-off on debt with the equity. So,
Ravi, remind me again what are the two
biggest benefits of borrowing money?
What's the biggest
two advantages?
You don't have to give up equity is not
a good reason, right? I mean, but that's
a control reason. It's got nothing to do
with reducing your cost of capital, but
that can be one of the secondary reasons
companies don't want to go out and
borrow money. So, we talked about
transitory reasons, psychological
reason, but a financial reason
not giving up a share of ownership,
especially if it's a publicly traded
company, it's not your company anyway,
shouldn't be a factor. Leon, what what
are the two biggest benefits?
Tax benefits because interest expenses
tax deductible. And I did mention that
there are variations across world.
There's one part of the world where debt
debt does not give you a tax advantage.
That's in much of the Middle East.
For religious reasons, you know, debt is
not encouraged, so interest is not
taxed. It's the one part of the world
where it's not true.
There is another part of the world where
there is actually a tax advantage for
equity as well. It's a very strange
setup. In Brazil, when you raise equity,
you're allowed to claim a tax deduction
called interest on capital, which means
you can take your book equity and
multiply by rate that the Brazilian
government gives for that year. So, it's
11% 11% of book equity you can claim as
a tax deduction. It was created so that
you could offset the tax benefits of
debt. But, in much of the world,
debt gives you a tax advantage. In some
parts of the world, there is a limit on
how much you can have in interest
expenses.
The including the US US 2017 tax code,
in addition to bring the marginal tax
rate down, interest expenses could not
exceed 30% of EBITDA. If they did, you
wouldn't get the tax saving anyway. So,
it reduces the tax benefit, but it's
still a tax advantage.
The second, of course, it can make some
companies more disciplined the way they
pick projects. What kinds of companies?
Mature companies, lots of cash flows
with a disconnect between management and
ownership. If it's your own money, this
would never matter, right? Because you'd
manage it well. But, if it's other
people's money,
there's this worry of, "Hey, people
might be sloppy. Borrowing money might
make you more disciplined." Two big
advantages.
Okay. Derek, what are the what are the
what are the costs of borrowing money?
What's What do you trade the benefits
off against?
Risk of bankruptcy, right? No matter who
you are as a company, when you borrow
money, you increase the likelihood that
you might not be able to make that debt
payment. Maybe from
1% to 0.03%.
That's the probability of bankruptcy.
And you multiply by the cost of going
bankrupt, which has two components. One
is the actual cost of bankruptcy, the
legal cost that sucks up so much of your
resources.
And the other is the indirect cost,
which is people perceive you to be in
trouble, you are in trouble.
Okay.
It's a bankruptcy cost.
Wait. What's the
What are the costs would you add to the
mix in addition to bankruptcy costs?
You're an equity investor. She's a No,
Kelly's a lender. You're an equity
agency cost. So, tell me again what
agency cost is. What What What What What
What What is it and why is it a problem
when you borrow money?
I'll get you started. You have You're an
equity investor. Kelly's a lender. Do
you both have the same
very different interests, right? Kelly,
because she's a lender, cares about
safety. You are an equity investor. You
want upside.
So, what does Kelly do when she lends
you money?
Covenants. Restricts you from doing
things. And for some companies, if
you're regulated, you turn around and
say, "I don't care." But, if you're a
technology company or a pharmaceutical
company, you say, "I don't want that
person looking over my shoulder telling
me what to do. I need to be able to
spend 60 billion in AI if I feel like
it."
Agency costs.
And that's some So, if you're a company
that values flexibility, for God's sake,
don't go out and borrow money. Then
complain about the fact that the banker
keeps looking over your shoulder. It's
exactly what you should expect. And a
related cost
is the loss of future flexibility, which
is if you borrow money today,
you can't borrow it later when you might
actually need it. So, it's good to
preserve some debt capacity for a future
day.
That's the trade-off.
And we looked at a very special case of
that trade-off,
that Twilight Zone episode where I put
in a world with no taxes, no default
risk,
and no agency problems, and the result
there was you can do whatever you want.
You can borrow 10%, 30%, 50%. It's a
Miller-Modigliani theorem where it
doesn't matter what you borrow. It's a
very special case.
The world is not a Miller-Modigliani
world. You can borrow too much.
You can borrow too little.
And today we're going to talk about how
to actually find that right mix. We
ended the class with that financing
hierarchy.
Remember that if you were given a choice
as a company and you're a manager, you
value control and you value flexibility.
So, given a choice, you'd rather fund
everything with retained earnings
because nobody's asking you questions.
The minute you go outside the company
to borrow money or to raise equity, it
comes with a catch. Now you've got to
explain what you're going to do and you
don't want to do that.
And you give up some control, you give
up some flexibility. But in terms of the
hierarchy, retained earnings is on top.
Straight debt, the conventional debt is
second, and then you get convertible
debt, preferred stock, and at the very
bottom of the list I said is convertible
preferred stock.
So, I ended the class by saying if you
have a prospect or tombstone where you
see what a company is using, you can at
least guess what kind of
financial health the company has. And
here's an example. This is just a couple
of years ago, just before
Bed Bath & Beyond kind of closed its
doors and declared bankruptcy.
It declared that it was making a
convertible preferred stock and warrant
offering.
Why when you get so deep in the hole is
uh convertibles and warrants actually
going to become more attractive? What's
the only thing you have to offer the
world? We're a risky company.
And the only security that benefits from
risk is options. So, not surprisingly,
you're going to see a lot of options and
convertible bonds because that's the
only way you can raise money.
But that's not a good sign when you see
a company do that.
So,
what I'd like to do today actually is to
put some more specifics. Because right
now, if you look at your company, you
can make a judgment. Can my company
borrow a lot or not very much? But if I
said, "How much is a lot of debt? Is it
20%? 30?" We don't have an answer to
that.
So, today I want to talk about what that
mix of debt and equity is for your
company.
Or put differently, you can look at your
existing debt ratio. Is this the right
debt ratio for my company?
I'm going to take you through five
different approaches. We're going to
spend uh most of our time on the first
approach because it kind of lays the
foundations for the other.
I'm going to go back to an instrument
we've already used in this class to make
other judgments, the cost of capital. It
was a hurdle rate when we did investment
analysis.
But I'm going to use it in a different
context. So, I'm going to use it as an
optimizing tool. I'm going to argue that
through the cost of capital,
I'll be able to find a mix of debt and
equity that's right for you as a
company.
The problem with that that basic cost of
capital approach is I'll make some
implicit or explicit assumptions that
you might not be comfortable with as to
what happens to rest of the company as I
borrow more money. The second approach,
I will take the cost of capital approach
and introduce some constraints so you
feel a little more comfortable saying,
"Okay, now I feel okay going with the
cost of capital."
The third approach is called the
adjusted present value approach. It was
developed at the University of Chicago
probably 40 years ago.
And if you run into University of
Chicago MBA, they'll talk about this
being the only way to optimize that.
I'm going to talk about how to do it
right and why in practice it's done in a
half-assed way and leads to some very
bad decisions on debt.
The fourth approach, and I know I firmly
believe that this is actually the
approach that most companies use. They
play pay lip service to cost of capital
or adjusted present value.
But if you caught them in an honest
moment and said, "Why is your debt ratio
30%?" You know what the answer is going
to be? Because everybody else in our
sector is at 30%. We'll talk about the
draw
of being where everybody else I call
this the me-tooism disease in corporate
finance.
Okay?
The peer group approach. And finally, we
already talked about the life cycle
approach.
Very low-tech, but very effective. Tell
me where you are in the corporate life
cycle, I'll guess what kind of debt
ratio you should have.
So, let's get the cost of capital
approach going and let's review how we
got cost of capital. We shouldn't really
need to because we just left it behind
when we did investment analysis.
The cost of capital is a weighted
average of your cost of equity and your
cost of debt, right?
The cost of debt is adjusted for the tax
benefit. There's where the tax benefit
of debt shows up. So, as you look at the
cost of capital, you have a cost of
capital and the existing debt ratio and
you can compute that cost of capital. I
did that for Disney, 7.81%.
88% equity, 12% debt.
The question we're asking is if I change
that debt ratio,
could I change my cost of capital?
Seems obvious it should, right? As I go
from 12% debt to 20% debt to 30% debt,
will my cost of capital change?
So, France, help me out here. If I go
from 12% debt to 20% debt, tell me the
good thing that happens to my cost of
capital. What might cause cause my cost
of capital to decrease?
But even before that, cost of equity is
higher than the cost of debt, right?
Even without tax benefits, you could
say, "Hey, my cost of capital is going
to go down." Of course, if you add the
tax benefit effect, the effect is even
greater. Debt is cheaper than equity.
I'm replacing more expensive financing
with cheaper debt.
Constantina,
what's the side effect of doing that? As
I go from 12% debt to 20% debt,
what should happen to my cost of equity?
And what instrument in my cost of equity
is causing my cost of equity to go up?
There's a risk-free rate, there's a
beta, there's an equity risk premium,
right? The risk-free rate and the equity
risk have nothing to do with your
company. So, the only thing you have
left is the beta.
And here you can see why the way we've
talked about beta helps us at this
stage. We don't get it from a
regression.
We get unlevered beta based on the
businesses you're in. We put in a
debt-to-equity ratio. Now, with a 20%
debt-to-equity ratio, the
debt-to-capital ratio, I have a higher
debt-to-equity, I'll have a higher
levered beta,
and a higher cost of equity.
So, my cost of equity will go up.
If I increase my debt from 12 to 20%,
that's almost doubling my debt. And
you're the banker.
Remember the cost of debt you had at 12%
based on a single A rating or an A+
rating?
Will that cost of debt be affected? So,
think like a lender. Now I'm doubling my
debt. Will you lend me money at the old
rate?
You shouldn't, right? I'm a riskier
company.
You're going to increase your cost of
debt because you see more default risk.
So, the cost of debt will also go up.
Now, do you see where the dynamic is?
You're replacing more expensive equity
with cheaper debt, but both the cost of
equity and the cost of debt go up. And
what you effectively will end up with is
a different cost of capital. Whether
it's lower or higher will depend on
whether the trade-off works in your
favor.
And as you do this, as you increase
debt, there's one more thing to keep
your eye on.
You increase debt, your interest
expenses go up, right?
And to claim the tax benefit on interest
expenses, what has to be true? Your
operating income has to be higher than
the interest expense. So, there'll be a
tipping point where the interest expense
will actually blow through your
operating income and you start to lose
the tax benefits as well. So, even the
tax benefit might be affected. So, the
whole process goes into play.
Now, I am always amazed when CFOs say,
"Borrowing money lowers your cost of
capital, right?" No. Right, it might, it
might not. It depends on where you are
in this process.
So, the cost of capital will change as
your debt ratio changes. It could go
down, it could go up. And say, "How does
this connect to an optimal mix of debt
and equity?"
Let me remind you again that the
objective in corporate finance is to
maximize the value of your business,
right? That was the original objective.
I'm going to use cost of capital in a
third way. Cost of capital is I've
described as a Swiss Army knife of
finance because it gets used in so many
different places.
In valuation, the cost of capital will
become the discount rate I use to get
the cash flows. But before we go to that
instrument, let me get let me dispense
with the
with a question I get
asked all the time about cost of equity
and cost of debt.
I've talked to CFOs again of especially
of family group companies in Asia who
claim that equity is cheaper than debt.
We kind of talked about this earlier in
the class. And their argument is a very
simple one.
The cost of debt is the interest rate
you pay on debt.
The cost of equity is the dividends you
pay on equity because that's the only
explicit cost to the company.
If my dividend yield is lower than my
interest rate, equity is cheaper than
debt. In fact, if I pay no dividends, my
cost of equity is what?
0%.
It's absurd, I know.
But if I'm the CFO make me argument,
tell me again what I'm missing when I
claim that the cost of equity is just
the dividend yield.
I'm not even required to pay a dividend
contractually.
So, what is going to go wrong with my
company if all I deliver
is a 2% dividend yield to you as an
equity investor?
What do you need to make as an equity
investor to forget about being happy,
just to break even?
You need the dividend. But do you invest
in equity? Why? Because you expected
some price appreciation, right?
When we compute an expected return, the
cost of equity, we're not just computing
dividends, we expect price appreciation.
We tie this to corporate governance.
Why? Because if you don't deliver price
appreciation, you cannot get sued. It's
not a contractual obligation. But your
shareholders are going to be pretty
pissed off at you.
And in a world where corporate
governance is strong, they're then going
to get you out of the way. They're going
to vote for a different board and
different management.
So, in companies with strong corporate
governance, it's going to connect very
quickly. Of course, the cost of equity
is higher than the cost of debt cuz we
have to deliver price appreciation.
But part of the reason we spent those
three sessions on corporate governance
is if you don't have that hook of a
strong corporate governance,
management will say, "Well, what are you
going to do to me?"
They would treat equity as free money.
It's exactly what Japanese companies did
in the late 1980s when they felt that
equity was free, and they would take
projects that made 2% to It allowed
Japanese companies to grow
exponentially.
But it caught up with them 6 7 8 years
later because they'd taken projects that
they never should have taken with a
reasonable cost of equity.
But the second question is actually a
question that you might get asked in
interview. Let's see if you can give me
the answer because it's a very tricky
question.
Can equity ever be cheaper than debt?
For a company.
For 99% of companies, the answer is of
course not, right? Because the debt
holder is ahead of you in line. If he's
charging 10%, you'll charge 12%. There's
one exception, though.
Anybody want to try to guess what kind
of company? Good.
It's more likely a stressed company
that's over leveraged. A distressed
company that's over leveraged. What's
going to happen to your beta then?
Right? Let's say you're 800% debt.
Your beta is going to be through the
roof. Your cost of equity is going to be
60 80 100%.
Right? The guy in front of you is
charging 30% to lend to the company. As
an equity investor, you have to charge
more.
Jacob, you want to try?
Um
I'll give I'll give you I'll get you
started. Cost of equity is driven by the
beta. Beta measures what kind of risk?
A risk that cannot be diverse. Let's say
you're a gold mining company. Remember
we talked about one of the the few
companies out there which have a lot of
risk, but most of the risk is company
specific. You can end up with a really
low beta. It doesn't even have to be
negative because most of your risk is
company specific. If you have a really
low beta, your cost of equity will be
low, but you could have a lot of other
risk which a lender is going to bring
into the cost of debt.
So, you could be a gold mining company
with a cost of equity that is actually
lower than the cost of debt. You're
saying that makes no sense. It makes
complete sense because then what should
that company do? It should fund itself
almost entirely with
equity. It should never borrow money. If
it borrows money, that doesn't make
sense.
So, can a company So, reserve this
question for when you come back to
interview and you've got this obnoxious
person person across the tape across the
table from you. You want to because this
is the the exception.
But for most companies, your cost of
equity should be higher than the cost of
debt.
So, with that in place, let's talk about
why the cost of capital can be used as a
vehicle
to optimize the debt ratio. The value of
a firm can be written as the present
value of the cash flows to the entire
firm discounted back at the cost of
capital.
That's just the value. That's plain
intrinsic valuation.
Let's assume I can keep the cash flows
fixed
and lower my cost of capital.
Go along with me. What's going to happen
to my present value? Same cash flows,
lower discount rate, my value goes up.
And at the limit, if I minimize my cost
of capital, what have I done to my
value?
I've maximized my value.
If I can minimize my cost of capital,
I've essentially maximized value. That's
my end game, my objective in corporate
finance. That is
my optimal debt ratio, the one that
minimizes cost of capital.
So, I'm going to pull up an example that
is
45 years old.
It was from my corp first corporate
finance class. I was an MBA student at
UCLA in course corporate finance class,
and the the professor came in
with an example of how to optimize debt
ratio.
He started off with an example of XYZ
widget company, which already made me a
little suspicious.
Cuz who talks about widget companies
when you got 48,000 real companies out
there? The advantage of widgets, you
don't know whether they're
discretionary, non-discretionary, high
beta, low You can make up the numbers.
He said, "Today we're going to talk
about how to optimize debt ratio."
So, he said, "XYZ widget company has
$200 million
in cash flows growing at 3% a year
forever." Cash flows are given.
And then he said, "I have a table here
of what will happen to your cost of
capital as your debt ratio goes from 0%
debt to 100% debt."
Already there's one debt ratio there
that can't even be viable. You cannot
have a company that's all debt. Why?
Because somebody's got to bear the
residual risk, right?
I mean, you can be 99.9%
debt. So, but this we're willing to
concede 100% you've rounded up. 0 to
100% debt.
And he said, "We're going to talk about
what's going to happen to the cost of
equity and the cost of debt as your debt
ratio changes."
So, at first he said, "As your debt
ratio changes, your cost of equity
should go up." And he gave a story. He
said, "Equity should get riskier." And
it made sense intuitively. Your equity
is a residual claim. If I borrow money,
I have interest expenses to pay. So,
what's left becomes more volatile.
But some person in the front row, not
me, put up his hand. He said, "But why
is it going up the way it is?" Because
to be quite honest, it looked like he'd
made up the numbers, right?
First half percent, 0.6%, Basically, it
looked So, you could see it going up. He
said, "Don't worry about how it's going
up. It's the principle that matters." We
let it pass. Then he went to the cost of
debt. And he said, "As you borrow more
money, you will have more default risk.
The cost of debt will go up." Again,
same guy in the front row put up his
hand and said, "But why is it going up
the way it is?" And he said, "It's just
the principle.
Don't worry about the mechanics."
And then of course, he took the cost of
capital as a weighted average, and he
said, "Ev- Can everybody see what the
optimal debt ratio is? It's a cost of
capital the cost of capital is minimized
because when the cost of capital is
minimized with the same cash flows and
growth rate,
my firm value is maximized." He didn't
re-
He didn't understand why we weren't
convinced.
The mechanics are pretty pretty obvious,
right? Cost of capital goes down, value
goes up, lowers cost
What we were not convinced about was why
is the cost of equity How do you come up
with the cost of equity at all of these
different debt ratios? Because in
practice,
all you have is the cost of equity and
the cost of debt at today's debt ratio,
right? That's all you have.
Everything else in this table looked
made up.
I remember coming out of the class
saying, "I want to figure out a way to
get the cost of equity and the cost of
debt at different debt ratios because
otherwise, this is useless. There's
nothing I can do with a real company."
And that is part of why we've approached
estimating cost of equity and cost of
debt the way we have. Because what I'm
going to do is use that approach to come
up with the cost of equity and the cost
of debt at different debt ratios. In
fact, we gave this guy such a hard time
that he decided we were just dimwitted.
So, he said, "You don't get this? Let me
show it to you as a graph." And he said,
"Now do you get it? The cost of capital
is the is the lowest point on the
graph."
Of course it is. Cost of capital is
minimized, firm value is maximized. That
was not what we were contesting. The
question is how would you get a table
like this for a Disney or an Adobe or
any other company you're faced with?
So, I'm going to go back to my Disney
cost of capital
and try to compute the cost of capital
at different debt ratios.
Just to remind you what that original
cost of capital was, this is where
Disney is right now in November of 2013.
Risk-free rate was 2.75%.
It's bottom-up beta. I know it's been a
long time based on the five businesses
it was in taking a weighted average.
Bottom-up levered beta is 1.00.
Equity risk premium is 5.76%. That's a
weighted average premium based on the
parts of the world they operate in. Cost
of equity of 8.52%.
The cost of debt I got by looking at
Disney's actual rating. Because with
single A rating, their default spread is
1%, so the cost of debt is 3.75%.
Disney's marginal tax rate was 36%.
Remember, this is pre-2017,
so tax rates in the US were much higher.
Cost of debt of 2.4%.
Weights were market value weights.
Market value of equity share price times
number of shares. Market value of debt
included interest-bearing debt and lease
commitments put together.
88% equity, 12% debt, cost of capital of
7.81%. That's the one point I know.
I need to take this one point and make
it look like that XYZ widget table.
So, let's take the easier half of this
equation,
which is the cost of equity.
To get the cost of equity at every debt
ratio, here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to go back to my unlevered
beta, which I already have, right?
Because I broken it down bottom-up beta.
And look at what will happen to that
beta at every debt ratio from 0 to 90%.
So, it's levered beta formula.
Basically, I get the levered beta.
As my debt ratio goes up, my levered
beta will go up. My levered beta goes
up, my cost of equity will go up.
Risk-free rate and equity risk premium
don't change. It's the same company,
same geographies. None of that stuff
changes.
For the cost of debt
when I first did this,
I tried to be lazy.
I don't doesn't take a lot of trying for
me to be lazy. It comes naturally to me.
Well, how do I get the cost of debt at
the existing debt ratio? A single A
rating, right? That I got from S&P.
I actually
faxed at that time. I faxed a page to a
student of mine who worked at S&P and
said, "Look, you know, I'm trying to get
a cost of debt for Disney at different
debt ratios." This was in 1996 when I
first did it. And I said, "At the rating
of their existing debt ratio, could you
fill out what S&P will give us ratings
at all of these other debt ratios?"
You know what the response I got was?
"Do it and then we'll tell you." I said,
"I'm not Disney. I can't go around
changing the debt ratio."
But the problem is you're not going to
be able to get an actual debt ratio at
all of those other
ratings.
But there's a way around that, right?
When you When you have a company that
doesn't have a rating, how do we come up
the cost of debt?
What did we use to come up with the cost
of debt when a company did not have a
rating?
Sorry?
We use the interest coverage ratio. And
we went to that look up table and did a
synthetic rating, right? You open the
door now, I'm going to walk through.
As I borrow money, what's going to
happen to my interest coverage ratio as
I borrow more money?
My interest expense is going to go up.
My coverage ratio is going to decrease.
I'm going to go to the table. My rating
is going to be lower as I go from 20,
30, 40, 50% debt. I'm going to get a
synthetic rating at every debt ratio.
That synthetic rating obviously is going
to be lower with higher debt ratios. My
cost of debt is going to go up.
That's the opening I'm going to use to
get the cost of debt at every debt
ratio. I'm going to make sure I have
enough income to cover the tax the
interest expense to get the tax benefit.
I now will have a cost of debt at every
debt ratio.
Cost of equity from the levered beta,
cost of debt from the synthetic ratings.
I'm going to take a weighted average and
I'm going to end up with a table that's
going to look just like the XYZ widget
company table. But now if you point to a
number in the table,
I won't say it's just a principle, take
it. I'll tell you this is how we got
where we are.
So, let's start.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
This one?
Okay, so let
Okay. So, let's say I have a business,
right? And you're my equity investor,
right? How What are the earnings you
get? Whatever earnings are left over
after interest expenses, right? As I
borrow more money,
your your income becomes more volatile
because you have to cover the interest
expense first, which is a fixed cost.
It's the business is not changing, but
the equity in the business can become
very risky. This is why real estate as a
business is a safe business. You know
what makes it risky? The 80, 85, 90%
that you borrow makes your equity slice
much more volatile.
So, businesses don't become riskier. The
unlevered beta stays the same, but the
levered beta captures the effect of debt
on your equity.
So, because we need an unlevered beta,
I'm going to
review how we got the unlevered beta.
One was to stay with the regression beta
and unlevered. Remember we use the
average debt to equity ratio? I don't
like that approach because it starts
with a regression beta. You're saying,
"What's wrong with a regression beta?"
Everything. It's backward looking. It's
noisy.
So, that's why we did the alternative,
which is to break Disney down by
business. So, this is not a new table.
This is the table we used way back 250
200 pages ago.
We broke it down by business, got an
unlevered beta for each business. We
came up with an unlevered beta for
Disney's operating businesses
of 0.9239. Cost of capital is an
operating business discount rate. So,
don't bring in cash. Don't Don't even
look at cash for the moment. Just focus
on the operating businesses.
That 0.9239 is basically what I'm going
to use as my unlevered beta.
So, already have the cost of capital at
one debt ratio, right?
When I have zero debt, what's my beta?
0.9239. My cost of equity will come from
that beta. There's no debt. That will
then become my cost of capital.
So, at every debt ratio, I'm going to
try to compute. For the interest
coverage ratio, I need an operating
income. So, let me lay the foundations
for that as well.
In the most recent year, which was 2012
for Disney, this is what the numbers
look like. 2000
Their operating income is about 9.45
billion, but that was before you
adjusted for leases. Remember this is
pre-2019.
The operating income adjusted for leases
is 10.03 billion. Hold on to that number
because you're going to see that number
show up over and over again when I do
the interest coverage ratio because
that's going to be in the numerator.
So, I know the unlevered beta. I know
the operating income.
Already you can see for your company,
this is going to be something you will
have at the time you enter this
assessment of what the right mix is, an
unlevered beta for your company, and the
operating income for your company.
So, let's do
the cost of equity
part. As I said, this
There's my debt to cap ratio, 0 to 90%.
I'm going to stop at 90 because going to
99, 95 seems absurd. 90% that's a lot of
debt. That's
you know, higher than the debt ratio at
typical LBO. As I go from 0 to 90% debt,
my debt to equity ratio climb climbs
more than proportionately.
I did this before the first quiz, but
let If you give me the debt to cap,
getting to a debt to equity becomes very
simple, right?
A debt to cap ratio of 40% means you
have $40 of debt, $60 of equity. 40 / 60
gives me a debt to equity ratio of
66.67%.
A debt to cap ratio of 90% means you
have $90 of debt, $10 of equity. 90 / 10
gives me 900%. My debt to equity ratio
climbs more than proportionately. My
unlevered beta stays the same, but as I
go through through each debt ratio, that
levered beta will now have the effect of
bringing in the additional risk of
create for my equity investor to
borrowing money.
You're saying, "Disney with a beta of
6.24?"
If you decide to do a leveraged buyout
of Disney, not a good idea.
The day after the leveraged buyout,
you're going to feel an immense amount
of risk as an equity investor and you
should, right?
Cuz you've been taken on this immense
amount of debt that you got to pay off
and the interest expenses,
your equity becomes because you've taken
that risk and magnified it by how much
debt you chose to have.
Get that levered beta, your cost of
equity cuz the risk-free rate and the
risk premium stay the same.
It's
It's It's also going to go up. At a 90%
debt ratio, my cost of equity is 39%.
So, let's say a CFO tells you, "My
objective is to minimize my cost of
equity."
What's the only mix that's going to
minimize your cost of equity?
Not the cost of capital, but the cost of
equity.
0% debt.
If your end game is you want the lowest
possible cost of equity, you've saved me
a host of trouble because you should not
borrow money. Because the minute you
borrow money, your cost of equity will
start to rise
because that additional risk will make
your equity riskier.
Now, let's talk about the cost of debt.
I'm going to take you through my cost of
debt calculation for one debt ratio at
10% and then we're going to do it
together at a 20% debt ratio so you can
see the process play out. Cuz I'm going
to give you an Excel spreadsheet that
does all of the debt ratios, but I want
you to be able to do it by hand if you
needed to so you could see every step
work out.
So, at a 0% debt ratio, of course, the
company has no debt. You know, EBITDA,
depreciation, EBIT are basically out of
the income statement.
So, the question I'm going to ask is if
I go from no debt to 10% debt, what's
going to happen to my cost of debt?
So, I'm going to take you through these
steps and with As I go through the step,
there's one step that is
I think problematic.
I want you to tell me which step is
going to be the problematic one.
So, as I go from 0% to 10% debt, the
first thing I need to do is compute how
much debt I will have in dollar terms.
To compute the dollar debt, I actually
start with the existing market value of
the firm, which I know. Market value of
equity plus market value of debt, 137.84
billion. 10% of that number is 13,784.
That's step one. I've got the dollar
debt.
The EBITDA, the DA, and the EBIT remain
exactly the same. It's the same company.
I multiply the dollar debt by an
interest rate to get the interest
expense. That's step two.
I divide the operating income by the
interest expense. I come up with an
interest coverage ratio of 23.1.
Remember that look up table? 23.1 puts
me way above 8.5, which is high. So, I
will give them a triple A rating
and a pre-tax cost of debt of 3.15%. Let
me list the five steps and you tell me
which one's the problematic one. I start
by getting a dollar debt. I multiply the
dollar debt by an interest rate to get
the interest expense.
I divide the operating income by the
interest expense to come up with an
interest coverage ratio. I use the
interest coverage ratio to come up with
a rating and I use the rating to come up
with an interest rate.
Kelly, help me out. Which step in that
process
is problem?
The first one, the dollar debt that I
can get, right? Because I get the value
of the firm. It's true. I'm using the
existing firm value. But to get the
interest expense, what did I do?
I multiply the dollar debt by an
interest rate,
but I don't even know the interest rate
yet, right? Because I need the interest
expense to get the interest rate, and
the interest
When you try this first on an Excel
spreadsheet, the spreadsheet will go
crazy on you.
It'll go crazy on you because there's
circular reasoning, right?
It is circular reasoning because to get
the interest expense, I need I need the
interest expense to get the interest
rate, the interest rate to get the
interest expense. Let's say you didn't
have a spreadsheet. You were doing this
by hand.
Right?
Here's what you do. You start with the
previous levels.
Cost of debt, which in the case of a
zero debt is triple A. So, start with
3.15% as your interest rate, compute an
interest expense, and in this case you
got lucky. Why? Because that interest
expense gave you an interest rate that
matched up.
Saying, "What if that doesn't happen?"
We're going to try that. Let's take the
20% debt ratio and work it through. I'm
sorry, the 30% debt ratio work it
through.
30% debt, I will have a debt to equity
ratio 42.86%.
That's 30 over 70.
To get the dollar debt at 30% debt, I
will need 41,352
million. That's 30% of the total value
of the firm, which was 137,839.
That's 41,352. EBITDA, the done, the
EBIT remain the same. It's the same
company, same project, same assets.
Nothing changes.
I multiply the 41,352 by the interest
rate from the previous level of debt
because I don't know it yet. I get an
interest expense of 1.302 billion.
Interest expense of 1.302 billion gives
me a interest coverage ratio of 7.7.
Go back to the previous page. Interest
coverage ratio of 7.7 gives me a double
A rating.
I give the double A rating and a cost of
debt of 3.45%. We have a problem. You
see what the problem is? The interest
rate I've used to come up with the
interest expense
doesn't match up to what I claim the
interest rate will be at that debt
ratio. But there's a fix, right?
I went back and recomputed the interest
expense at the 3.45% rate.
My interest expense, obviously, will go
up now. My coverage ratio will decrease,
and I very gingerly turn back to the
previous page hoping and praying what
hasn't happened.
That I haven't get done Yeah.
When I do this by hand, I've never had
to do more than two iterations.
The Excel spreadsheet is set up to do a
thousand iterations. So, it's overkill.
It doesn't cost it nothing. But
effectively, the spreadsheet just does
what you'd have done by hand is until
you get convergence, you've got to keep
doing this. In this case, I get
convergence at a double A rating. I'm
done with the 30% debt ratio.
If you want to try this out at a 40%
debt ratio, it's a great exercise. It's
good preparation for the third quiz, not
the second quiz. So, you might not want
to do it right now. Pick the 40% debt
ratio.
Do it by hand.
Start with the dollar debt. You get to
the interest expense and say, "What do I
do? Use the 3.45%?"
Cuz you know that from the 30%.
Compute the interest expense, come up
with an interest coverage ratio, come up
with the rating, come up with the cost
of debt. If it doesn't match, repeat the
process again.
I'm not going to torture you by taking
through you through 40, 50, 60, but this
is what it looked like when I was done
iterating.
So, this is the dollar debt
at every debt ratio. As I go from zero
to 90%, dollar debt grows
proportionately. It's always 10%, 20% of
that original value.
Right? And as Kelly pointed out, that
might be an issue because of original
value itself is shifting, but I need to
hold at least something stable.
Otherwise, the whole thing starts to
kind of
go into circular logic itself.
The interest expense will always rise
more than proportionately.
Why? Because as I go to more debt, my
interest rate is going up. So, as I go
from 10, 20, so my interest expense goes
from no interest at no debt to $16.4
billion
in interest expense
at 90% debt.
My interest coverage ratio, as my
interest expense goes up, remember my
EBIT stays the same, drops from 23 down
to 0.61. By the time you get to 80, 90%
debt, my interest expense is actually
higher than my operating income. My
interest coverage
I'm a basket case company, and why
should I be surprised? I've borrowed
immense amounts of money.
But there's one more thing I'm going to
do. The The pre-tax Once I get the
synthetic rating, which obviously is
going to decrease as the coverage ratio
drops, and the cost of debt, I'm also
going to
compute the marginal tax rate I'm going
to apply on that interest expense. It's
a marginal tax rate, right? Shouldn't
change.
And in fact, until you get to about 60%,
you see the tax rate stays at 36%.
Saying,
"Why at 70% is my First, is this a good
thing or a bad thing from a cost of debt
perspective have to have a lower tax
rate?"
It's a bad thing because it pushes on my
I am losing tax benefits. And the
question is, what's happening?
Well, if you look at my interest
expenses I go from 60 to 70 to 80%, my
interest expense is actually now
starting to get to be higher than my
operating income.
And I'm saying, "Stop. You can't deduct
more than your operating income. I can't
claim the extra tax benefit."
Now, you might wonder how I come up with
this 32.6, 26.8.
So, I'm going to take you through the
70% debt ratio so you can see how the
tax rate
is affected. So, up to 60%, I have no
problems.
My interest expense is less than my
operating income. I claim the full tax
benefit.
I get to 70% debt, my interest expense
becomes 11.096
billion, higher than my 10,032.
And the most I can deduct is the 10,032.
That's, you know, the entire operating
income. I get the full tax benefit up to
10,032
at 36.1%.
That's 3,622 million in tax benefit.
My interest expense, though, is 11,096.
So, effectively, that 10,032 becomes my
cap on how much I can deduct. And if my
interest expense keeps going up above
that,
there's no more tax benefit. So, the
effective tax rate I apply on that cost
of debt will decrease.
The effect will be to push up your
after-tax cost of debt even more at
those high debt ratios.
You see what I'm trying to do, right? I
I don't want you to end up at a 97% debt
ratio as your optimal
because no sane company can pull that
off.
So, I'm trying to pull you away from the
cliff saying, "Don't go too close to
that
because your tax benefits will be gone.
Your rating will be in the toilet. Your
cost of debt is going to be sky-high."
And I'm trying to bring that all into
the cost of capital.
So, cost of equity goes up because the
beta goes up. The cost of debt will go
up because the rating decreases, and
your tax benefits will be gone.
I think I can pull the numbers now into
a table that looks very much like the
XYZ Widget Company.
So, this is Disney's cost of capital
schedule
when your debt ratio goes from zero to
90%.
The beta goes up, your cost of equity
goes up. The after-tax cost of debt
increases because the rating drops, and
the tax rate is adjusted. In the last
column, you see the optimal the cost of
capital at each of the debt ratios.
What's my end game again? I want to
minimize my cost of capital, right?
Right now they're at 12% debt
with a 7.81% cost of capital. But to the
extent that I trust this table,
it looks like that cost of capital will
keep dropping until they get to about
40% debt.
Where it's minimized, and then it starts
rising again. But by now you can see the
dynamics that cause it to rise. At some
point in time, that implosion you're
creating in your cost of equity and cost
of debt start to push your cost of
capital up. So, while you continue to
replace more expensive equity with
cheaper debt, your cost of capital goes
up.
The optimal debt ratio, if your end game
is to minimize cost of capital,
is a 40% debt ratio, which leaves
unanswered the question, "Why would
Disney then stay at 12%?" We'll come
back and talk about why companies
rational companies might choose not to
go all the way up to the optimal. There
are good reasons
and bad reasons for doing it.
But clearly, Disney, at least in in
November of 2013,
if you look at their actual and their
optimal, has exceeded that capacity.
Any questions on the mechanics? So, try
it out by hand with a different debt
ratio. If you can do it with your own
company, even better. And I'll send you
the Excel spreadsheet that'll do the
optimal debt ratio for you, but don't
make it a black box.
Don't say, "The capital structure
spreadsheet told me the optimal was
40%." All it's doing is doing what we
did by hand. So, it cleans up the
process, does the iteration so that you
don't have to go through two or three
steps. But if you had to do this with a
pencil and a paper, you could actually
do this with a calculator. It's not a
big deal.
It It might take you a couple of hours
instead of the 2 minutes that
spreadsheet does, but you're effectively
computing the cost of capital at every
debt ratio.
Yes.
Yeah.
How often do you think you have to
recalculate the optimal cost of capital?
So, which direction do which direction
do you think the cost of the debt ratio
will change? Let's say that the
risk-free rate goes up.
Will my debt ratio optimal debt ratio
decrease, increase, or give me a sense
of direction?
Yeah, but I'm saying it let's there are
only two inputs here, right? Cost of
equity and cost of debt. So, when
risk-free rate goes up, what happens to
my cost of equity?
It'll go up. What happens to my cost of
debt? It'll also go up. By itself,
interest rates have very little effect
on optimal mixes.
What will affect that? We'll talk about
the other things that come in. The level
of rates, and that's why when people
talked about hey, companies should
borrow more money at 2% rates. Why
aren't they borrowing it? Because both
the cost of equity and the cost of debt
come It's like a rising tide or a
falling tide. Interest rates by
themselves are not altering your mix.
You know what would really alter your
mix? What drives your interest coverage
ratio?
Whatever is operating income.
If you think a recession is coming or a
downturn or a disruption that will cause
that number to collapse, that will
change your optimal debt ratio.
So, if you have a shock to your
business, you definitely should revisit
your optimal debt ratio.
But the macro effects on your debt ratio
are relatively minor.
The micro effects are what you have to
worry about as a company. And that And
obviously hopefully your operating
income is not changing every day, every
week. It's you know, it should be
infrequent enough that you don't have to
do But you have to do this at least at
regular intervals because things do
change in the external environment.
So, I did my own version of that XYZ
widget widget company. It's not quite
U-shaped, right?
It's a very very shallow V.
So, there's
And in fact, once you get to the
optimal, notice how what happens to the
cost of capital. It starts to climb very
quickly.
Now, do you see why you might not want
to go all the way to your optimal
because there's a tipping point.
Where if you hit that tipping point, you
very quickly spiral in. So, if you're
going to make a mistake on financial
leverage, on debt ratios, it's better to
be under leveraged
than over leveraged.
It's better to stay But it's good to
know what your optimal is. Doesn't mean
you shouldn't know the optimal. But if
Disney said, "Should we be at 30 or 50?"
I would say it's better for you to be
stay at 30 because the mistake you're
making is a slightly higher cost of
capital than the optimal. But I'd rather
you kind of hold back on pushing all the
way to the optimal than pushing through
it and ending up with the spiral, the
debt spiral on ratings and cost of debt
that cause your
cost of capital to explode.
The first edition of this book came out
in 1998, the applied corporate finance
book.
And that's the first time I did the
optimal debt ratio for Disney.
And that time I grafted out just like I
did.
And that Excel spreadsheet that you're
going to get is in earlier versions been
around for more than 25 years on my
webpage, and people downloaded they use
it. I really don't care.
No, but I remember sitting in my office
and a First Chicago banker. This is how
long ago this was. First Chicago is no
longer in existence because it was
bought by Chase and Chase became part of
JP Morgan.
I knew they were downloading the
spreadsheet, using it to come up with
optimal mixes, and presenting to their
clients as First Chicago analysis.
I said, "Okay, that's fine, and I don't
need a piece of the because I don't want
to have any part of what you're telling
them to do."
So, I'm sitting in my office and I get a
call from a First Chicago banker. He
says, "I'm calling from a restroom."
So, why the hell are you calling me from
a restroom?
He says, "Something very embarrassing
has happened."
Call your mother.
Huh?
He said, "No, no, not that kind of
embarrassing. I'm in the middle of a
client presentation
where I'm coming up with the optimal
debt ratio. I've used your spreadsheet,
and I put up this graph, and there's a
kink in the cost of capital.
Why? Takes a lot of gumption
to download a spreadsheet of somebody's
webpage, use it for commercial purposes,
and then turn around and say, "Why and
you know
So, he's talking about You can see the
kink in '97, right? You see where it
goes up.
Can you tell me what it is about the way
we're computing cost of capital at
different debt ratios that might create
the kink? Because I told him But you
could probably have told him as well.
What are the two numbers that drive my
cost of capital? Cost of equity, cost of
debt. It has to be one of those things
moving discontinuously.
Cost of equity moves continuously,
right? Every time my debt ratio changes,
my cost of equity changes. But when does
my cost of debt change?
Is when my interest coverage ratio
changes enough for me to slip down the
ratings table.
Right? So, if I borrow more money and my
interest coverage ratio leaves me in the
same segment of the interest coverage
ratio, I give you the same cost of debt.
In the real world, that wouldn't happen.
You could be a double B rated company,
but you can have a higher interest rate
than another double B rated company
because you have more debt.
So, I went through it and said, "Look,
that's what's happening. I'm using an
interest coverage ratio table. The
rating is discontinuous.
And that can cause this to happen." He
said, "How do I make it go away?"
So, I told him I said, "There are two
things you can do.
The first is that table that I've
created for the synthetic ratings is
completely my table, right? I can make
it double A plus plus plus I can start
to split the table up into finer and
finer you know, so it'll be 50 line
items then.
And you know, you can come up And if you
do that, then you're less likely to be
stuck in that same segment." He said,
"That sounds like a lot of work."
So, look.
So, I gave him a second suggestion. I
said, "How strong is your statistics?"
He said, "I barely remember them." And I
said, "Well, then you're probably in
trouble because the second thing you can
do is the only reason I need a rating is
to get a cost of debt, right? What if I
could take the interest coverage ratio
and directly connect to the cost of
debt? In other words, forget about the
rating.
That'll require, you know, some some
process very much like a levered beta
process. Where if you tell me what your
interest coverage ratio is, then this is
what the interest rate should be."
He said, "That is too complicated."
I said,
"Tell me again where the kink in your
cost of capital is. Is it right at your
optimal?" He said, "No, it's around It's
like in this table where And I said,
"Then why does it matter? Your optimal
debt ratio is your optimal debt ratio.
Why If you can explain that there why
there's a kink, why does it matter that
there other than for cosmetic reasons?
I've never felt the urge to smooth out
the kink. But if you do find a kink in
your cost of capital,
it's because of that part of the
process, that discontinuous cost of debt
where the ratings are not changing
continuously as the debt ratio changes.
The optimal is the optimal. It's still
40%. And why is it the optimal? Because
my cost of capital is lower at that debt
ratio than at every other debt ratio.
So, let's convert this percentage
optimal into dollar values because
you're probably going to find the number
a little shocking when I convert to
dollar value.
At a 40% debt ratio,
Disney will need to have about $55
billion in debt.
Disney right now has about 16 billion in
debt.
So, if you if So, if you were advising
Disney, what are you advising them to
do? Go out and borrow 39 billion. Here's
the part that I left out.
As I
from 0% to 10% to 20% to 30% debt,
remember my EBIT and my debt and my EBIT
stayed exactly the same. You see, "Where
is all this money going?"
Cuz if you're raising,
at each stage, 13, 14 billion dollars,
you know what I'm doing? I'm taking that
money and I'm using it to bring down my
equity by either paying a dividend or
buying back stock. It's called a
recapitalization. I'm essentially
leaving the company's asset side of the
balance sheet fixed and changing just
the mix of debt and equity. Why? Because
I want to isolate the effect of
financing mix.
If I let Disney take projects with that
extra 14 billion in debt,
it creates a second factor, right?
What's a net present value of the
project? I don't want that affecting my
financing mix.
Whenever you optimize debt ratios, you
have to do it. You have to hold the
business fixed and change just the mix
of debt and equity.
So, here's the advice I'm giving Disney,
and you're going to see very quickly why
they're going to be a little hesitant to
to run with it. I want Disney to go out
and borrow 39 billion dollars
and buy back stock.
That's a
big deal, right?
So, if Disney's management has any
sense,
there should be three questions they
should ask. If any management, if you
tell them to go out and borrow
huge amount of debt and buy back stock,
the first question should be,
"Why should we do it?
What do we gain
by going out and borrowing 39 You're
saying, "It's obvious. Your cost of
capital will be lower, 7.16%."
That doesn't quite have the heft, right?
Because you want me to borrow 39 billion
dollars to reduce my cost of capital by
65 basis points, 0.65%.
Sounds like I'm doing too much to get
too little. I've got to convert that
0.65% cost of capital into real money.
Why should we do it? Second, what if
something goes wrong?
Like what? What if there is a recession?
What if the theme park has to shut down?
What if there's a pandemic?
Good question to ask anytime you borrow
money. What if something goes wrong? And
third,
what if we don't want to buy back stock?
We have all these plans to grow as a
company. It seems silly to borrow the
money and buy back stock when we have to
raise money to build more theme parks
and movies. Can we use the debt
that you claim that debt capacity you
claim we have to take projects instead
of buying back stock? Legitimate
questions, right? Why should we do it?
What if something goes wrong? And can we
use this debt capacity to do an
acquisition, to take projects?
So, let's take each of those questions
and the answers I'm going to come up
with at Disney a generic
approach based on generic approaches
that you can apply in any company.
Let's start with the first one. Why
should we do it?
Lower cost of capital, right? But why
does a lower cost of capital help?
Because it increases my value as a firm.
So, let's first figure out how much
Disney's value as a firm will increase
if they go to their optimum.
Right now, they're I don't know So, I
computed the cash flow to Disney as a
company. It's a little ahead of the game
because we'll get to this later in
valuation, but this is how we computed
cash flows for projects.
You know, you start with the operating
income, you add back depreciation,
subtract capex, subtract change in
working capital. 3.657 billion.
Their existing value. If you take their
existing enterprise value, market value
of equity plus debt minus cash, 133.9
billion. So, the first thing I did was I
said, "Let's assume the market is
valuing the company correctly." Because
this stage I want to focus on financing
mix. Given the cash flows in their
existing cost of capital, what is the
growth rate that the market is assuming
Disney will be able to have? So, this is
pure algebra. 133.9 billion is my value,
3.657 billion is the cash flow, 7.81%
is their existing cost of capital. Based
on what the market seems to be valuing
the company at, if you back out the
growth rate, you come up with a 4.94%
growth rate. That growth rate troubles
me, and I'll tell you in a minute why it
is troubling, but the pure math gives me
that. That's called an implied growth
rate. I'm backing it out of the market
and saying this is what the market is
building in.
So, tomorrow, let's say Disney goes out,
changes its debt ratio to 40%. Take a
look at this equation. 3,657 is a
pre-debt cash flow. That doesn't change.
The growth rate of 4.94% is in that cash
flow. That doesn't change. The only
thing that changes is the seven the cost
of capital, which goes from 7.81 to
7.16%.
You revalue Disney with the lower cost
of capital. The value that you get is
172.9
billion.
This is like magic, right? Same company,
same project, same business. All I did
was change the debt ratio, and I've
increased the value by 39 billion.
How the heck do you create I mean, this
is like
what the LBO guys say. We've created
value, 39 billion value.
I think I've overstated the value
increase, and I'll talk in a minute
about why when I do this I've done. But
you can see the effect on value comes
from having a lower cost of capital.
The flaw in this approach is that 4.94%
growth rate. That growth rate I'm
assuming is a growth rate you can
maintain forever.
And I don't think you can pull that off
in a in a risk-free rate of 2.75%. This
is too high a growth rate to sustain
forever.
So, I'm going to give you a shortcut
that I prefer when I look at change in
value from cost of capital. One way to
think about the cost of capital is it's
what it's costing you to fund the
company today.
So, if you look at the cost of capital
of 7.81% they have right now, and the
value of the firm, the current market
value of the firm, right now at their
existing cost of capital, it's costing
them about 10.46 billion a year to fund
the firm.
After they change their debt ratio,
they're going to have a 7.16%
cost of capital, which means the cost of
funding this firm has gone from 10.46
to 9.6 billion. Every year, I'm saving
about 866 million dollars.
You can take that saving each year and
look at the present value of the
savings. And here I can put a cap on
that savings. I'm not going to let it
grow at a rate faster than the risk-free
rate. And we'll talk about why the
risk-free rate is a is a good proxy for
that long-term growth.
8.866
million growing at 2.75%
a year in perpetuity with a 7.16% cost
of capital increases my value by 19.6
billion
if Disney goes to its optimum.
I'm not going to talk about the cost of
capital dropping by 65 basis points.
That's not going to be effective. You're
going to increase your value as a
company by 19.6 billion. But it still
feels like magic, right?
What Where is this increase in value
coming from? It's the same theme park,
same movies.
Where is this increase in value coming
from?
It's like the laws of physics. You can't
create something out of nothing. It has
to come from someone, somewhere. Where
is this 19.6 billion value coming from?
I know it's coming from a lower cost of
capital, right?
But why is my cost of capital lower at a
40% debt ratio?
Because
truth debt is cheaper. And the debt is
cheaper because of
a tax saving.
If I make the tax rate 0%, you know what
the optimal debt ratio here will be? 0%
debt.
This entire increase in value is not
coming from better project, great
investments. It's a transfer of wealth.
And I'm not going to It's not a moral
statement that I'm going to make. It's a
transfer of wealth to Disney from whom?
Taxpayers.
Right? So, the next time an LBO guy gets
up and boasts about how much value
they've created, you got to stop them
and say, "You're not creating value,
you're moving value around." In fact, if
the only thing you're seeing in an
economy is recapitalizations
and leveraged transactions, the economy
is not getting better off, right? All
you're doing is shifting value. Again,
I'm not It's entirely
I It's not an ethical statement. The tax
law is what it is. You didn't write the
tax law, you're taking advantage of it.
But don't go around telling people
you're creating value by taking This is
not about taking better projects,
building more theme parks, making better
movies. It's about using the tax law
to essentially transfer wealth legally
from taxpayers to yourself.
That's where the entire increase in
value comes from. It's that tax. So,
that's why if you go to the spreadsheet
and make your tax rate 0%, that entire
value increase will disappear.
So, why should we do it? First step is
lower cost of capital. Then you convert
that lower cost of capital into a value.
You can see that effect play out.
Now, of course, there's a practical
question. To do this, I need to go out
and buy back stock, right? And the
question is, "What price should I pay to
buy the stock back at?"
Anyway, but this is a going to be a big
buyback. You can't just slip into the
market, do a little at a time. You got
to do what's equivalent of a tender
offer, what you see in acquisitions. So,
Disney has to take a full-page ad
saying, "If you're a Disney shareholder,
you can put your shares back to us, and
we will pay you X dollars." We set the
stage. The stock price at the time of
this transaction of this analysis was
$67.71.
I want you to play the role of Disney
shareholders. You're all shareholders in
Disney.
You own the shares now at 67.71. I'm
planning to do this major buyback.
And I'm going to make a tender offer for
the shares. Can I make a tender offer at
67.71?
I could, but nobody would submit the
shares, right? So, almost by definition,
I have to offer a premium.
If you let your bankers determine that
premium,
what are they going to do? Offer a huge
premium because it makes their job
easier. The larger the premium, the
easier the buyback goes.
But remember, when you pay that premium,
you're essentially that cash is leaving
the company. And you want to be fair
because there are two groups of people
here. One is the shareholders who will
sell their shares back, so you guys can
be those shareholders, and the
shareholders who will stay with the
company.
If this were a fair universe, and I know
it's not,
that 19.6 billion dollars in firm value,
everybody should get an equal share of
it, right? The people who sell back, the
people who remain.
I'm going to call that my rational
solution. I'm using the word rational
with quotes around it. If this were a
rational universe where companies paid
fair value,
then I would pay the same the price that
I pay on my buyback should be roughly
equal to the price left for the
shareholders behind.
It actually makes my life easier because
what it means is I can take the increase
in firm value and divide by the total
number of shares outstanding, even
though I know that share count is going
to drop. That gives me an extra 10.90.
If you add the 10.90 on, I can offer
$78.61
on my buyback.
And if I can pull it off at that price,
here's what'll happen.
The people who sell their shares back
will get 10.90 a share. The people who
are remaining in the company will also
get 10.90 a share. You'll be indifferent
between selling back and not selling
back.
The only reason you might sell back is
why? If you're are the same amount, why
might some people sell back and others
not sell back?
One is if you do sell back,
there's a tax consequence, right?
You got to pay capital gains and if you
need the cash, you're saying I don't
care, but if you
don't want to bear that tax consequence,
you don't need the cash and you don't
sell back, you get the same increase in
value, but there's no tax attached
because you haven't sold the shares.
That's a pure tax choice,
but you're giving people that choice.
This is the rational solution because
effectively everybody gets an equal
share. It almost never happens.
In the real world,
companies either pay too much on
buybacks or pay too little. Which
mistake do you think is more common? Pay
too much on buybacks or pay too little?
They pay too much because bankers that
that you are you hire a banker to get
they makes their life easier to set the
price too high. And if you don't have a
reservation price,
which is what we have here, you're going
to keep pushing the price up until you
can sell the shares.
So, here's the more general solution of
what happens when you buy back shares.
First,
start with the increase in debt you
have. So, the the case of Disney, that's
the $39 billion in debt. The shares you
will buy back will be based upon the
share price you pay on the buyback. So,
it'll be the increase in debt by the
price you pay on the buyback. So, you
could pay 79.61, you could pay 84, you
could pay 90, you could pay 95. The
higher the price, the fewer the shares
you will buy back with that same dollar
debt.
Compute the shares left over after the
buyback and that share will be the
shares before minus the shares you
bought back.
Then take the value of the firm after
you do the buyback and divide the equity
value by the remaining shares
outstanding.
What you will then get is two different
prices, one for the buyback, one for the
remaining shareholders.
And those prices can be different. One
group is going to get gypped
relative to the other one
if you don't pay a fair price.
So, first let's check that 78.61 to see
if it works, if it is in fact a fair
price. So, I took the 39,175
million additional debt divided by and
so, this is actually you know, let me do
the 79.6 78.61 first. Divide by the
78.61. Remember that was the rational
price?
I'll have 1,301.65
million shares outstanding after the
buyback at the rational price.
If you look at the enterprise value at
that optimal debt ratio, the enterprise
value is 153.53
billion. That's a 19.6 billion added on.
Plus cash minus debt, there's the equity
value, 102 billion. You divide the
equity value by the shares outstanding,
here's the magic, you get exactly the
same price. This is a fair world because
everybody gets exactly the same increase
in value.
That's why it's rational.
Is it possible that Disney could have
bought the shares back at the 67.71?
Could be, right?
I remember the Bass brothers used to be
big shareholders in Disney and they had
a they were these Texas-based
billionaires had a bad deal
deal gone they needed cash in a hurry.
Let's suppose you have a large
shareholder in your company in Disney
who needs cash in a hurry. It's entirely
possible they'll take the 67.71.
So, if I paid 67.71,
so the people who buy sell the shares
back are selling for 67.71. You can
already see who's going to benefit,
right?
You as a remaining shareholders are
going to get the entire increase in
value for yourself and here's how it
plays out. I'll be buying back more
shares because I paid a lower price. If
I take the equity value and divide by
the share count now,
the value for the remaining shares will
be 83.78. So, you got 67.71,
they got 83.78.
It's not fair, but you sold the shares
back. Nobody put a gun to your head said
you got to sell. So, already you can see
you can play with different buyback
prices.
Try this out when you get a chance. Put
in a $90 buyback price. The banker got
crazy, offered $90. Play the game out.
You can already see that at a $90 share
price, you're going to end up with a
much lower stock price. In fact, there
is a price I can pay on the buybacks
where you will actually end up with a
price per share less than 67.71
if I overpay enough. There's only 19.6
billion in spoils to go around.
So, if I keep upping the price and I
don't watch out, there will be a tipping
point where I will be paying 19.6
billion plus to the people who share
sell back their shares.
And that's why when when I write about
buybacks, again, it's very difficult to
make a generic statement. Are they good,
the bad the bad? Buybacks don't create
value. They can transfer wealth from the
shareholders who don't buy back to the
shareholders who buy back or or or the
reverse depending on what the buyback
price is.
So, when you do the optimal, you can
come up with that extra dollar debt and
you can work through will that make
sense. Any questions on this process of
working through what will happen to your
stock price at different numbers, right?
Which brings us to the second question,
what if something goes wrong?
If you're ever on the consulting or the
banking side of this
pitch where you're telling companies
they have excess debt capacity and then
somebody in the management say, what if
something goes wrong? Here's the one
answer you should never give.
Nothing will go wrong.
It's almost like you're tempting the
fates while you're standing there
because before you even leave the room,
something will go wrong.
So, when management say, what if
something goes wrong, turn the question
back on them. Said, tell me what the
things you worry about most are because
let's face it,
they're more immersed in their business
than you and I ever will be. So, telling
them nothing will go wrong is both you
know, both unrealistic and really
doesn't reflect the knowledge of the
business you need for that.
So, if you are a defense contractor,
what is the thing that could go wrong
that could alter your value?
You could lose that contract, which is
60% of your revenues. You're a
manufacturer, you get 35% of your
revenues from Walmart, they're your
biggest customer, that could If you're a
cyclical company, it could be a
recession.
If you're a hotel company, it could be a
pandemic, right? So, it could be
different things and your job then is to
say, let's look at what happens to your
optimal
if that thing unfolds. A recession, a
pandemic, loss of contract.
So, when you do the optimal, that's your
first It's not the end of the game, it's
the start of a process where you say,
let's check to see how sensitive this
optimal is
to changes in your operating income.
That's a key driver of your optimal debt
ratio. So, you could say, do what if and
I what if my operating income drop by
10%, 20%, 30%? Looking at history to see
what a bad year looks like for you as a
company.
The second thing you can do is run
different scenarios on your operating
income. What happens in a recession,
what happens in a recovery to see what
the optimal look like under each
scenario. You want your company to
survive across scenarios, not just in
your best case scenario or expected
scenario.
So, one way to ask what if questions is
through the operating income and seeing
how it plays out.
The other is through the rating process.
Remember I came up with a synthetic
rating for the company at every debt
ratio and then I used to come up with
the optimal debt ratio for the firm.
I didn't check at the optimal what the
rating for the company was.
What if the rating was double B?
Would that trouble you as a company if I
told you to go to a double B rating even
if it gave you the lowest cost of
capital?
What's the magic magical thing about you
know, about ratings, you know, about
triple B in ratings? What's what what is
that divide?
Investment grade from non-investment
grade.
You're saying who cares? Once you fall
below investment grade, things get more
difficult. Used to be impossible at one
point in time, they get more difficult
raising more capital. It's not just your
cost of debt goes up, people start to
worry. Remember we talked about indirect
bankruptcy costs? That's when those
indirect bankruptcy costs. So, I think
it's legitimate for companies to say, I
want the lowest cost of capital subject
to a rating constraint.
Investment grade or maybe one notch
above investment grade because you want
to give some buffer.
Once in a while you will get a company
that says, I want a triple A rating.
You know, that's that's a rating
constraint as well. We'll talk about how
to separate realistic constraints from
unrealistic constraints.
So, I'm going to end today's class by
looking at Disney's history.
What am I trying to estimate? What is a
bad year for Disney look like?
You think wouldn't it be the same for
every company your operating income
decreases? That's true.
For Con Ed, a bad year is a 10% drop in
operating income. For Dell, a bad year
is a 60% drop in operating income,
right? Different businesses, different
downsides.
You have to look at your own history.
And in this case, when you look at the
history of Disney going back to '87,
there's the worst year Disney's ever
had, 2000, down 29.47%.
2009 was pretty bad, too, 23%.
So, already you can see it's going to
frame your what if question. You're not
going to ask what if operating income
drops by 80%, that's not Disney's
history. You're going to drop by 10%,
maybe 20, 30.
I did also look at the last four
economic recessions leading into before
this was in 2013. And I looked to see
how Disney did and then
it's operating income got a hit 15, 20.
Though in 1981, their operating income
actually increased by 12%. That's way
back in time.
So, there No, Disney obviously can have
bad years. A bad year for Disney is
probably a 20% or a 30% drop in
operating income.
And all I had to do was go into my Excel
spreadsheet, take the 10,032 million
operating income, drop it by 10, 20, 30
to see what would happen to my optimal.
You see,
it's going to go down.
By how much? Let's say if I drop it by
10%, the optimal goes back to to 10%
debt ratio.
I'm going to tell Disney probably should
stay at a 12% debt ratio because a small
drop in your operating income
will make you over levered.
What I found instead though, as as I
dropped my operating income by 10 or
20%, the optimal stayed unchanged till I
got to about a 40% drop in operating
income, which Disney had never seen in
its history.
You know what? This is a great tool for
dealing with managers who are so
inherently conservative
that they can see the excess debt
capacity, but they're saying, "What if
something goes wrong?" So, what do you
do? You take what can go wrong, you put
it in and say,
"You know what? Even if your worst-case
scenario unfolds, you should be at a 20%
debt ratio. You're at 5% debt."
So, go to the 20% if that's what you're
comfortable doing.
Your job is not to push management to
borrow more money, but to get them to
borrow enough money that they can
run this company comfortably, still make
the right decisions without having to
worry about the debt components driving
their choices.
So, what if something goes wrong, let it
play out. Next session we start off,
we'll start with rating constraints, why
companies impose rating constraints, and
how to bring them in. But, I will send
you the link to the Excel spreadsheet.
For the moment, I know you're going to
be working on the second quiz, but if
you get a chance, might want to play
with it. Your company.